comme chaque année le salon des arts
ménagers a choisi sa magicienne la fée
du logis 1956 dans les sous sols du
grand palais elle était 120 en
compétition pour les demi finales
cent vingt jeunes filles et jeunes
femmes venus de toutes les provinces de
france après avoir triomphé des preuves
multiples départementales et régionales
une fée du logis ne peut être bien sûr
kabyle cordon bleu pour en juger on leur
fit faire des rissoles des pommes
meringuée c'est l'union nationale des
caisses d'allocations familiales qui
organise ce grand concours
d'enseignement ménager
après la cuisine le raccommodage c'est
difficile la pose d'une pièce ronde
l'aspirante fait est interrogé par une
technicienne des sciences ménagères
mademoiselle morin l'une des
organisatrices du concours
il fallut encore taillé recoudre la
barboteuse deux bébés dans un tissu rayé
et le raccord des rayures
c'est aussi une technique délicate
[Musique]
la fée du logis sera naturellement la
plus compétente des mamans la
puériculture est à l'honneur et les
résultats fort encourageants
quand l'enseignement ménager progresse
la mortalité infantile diminue des mains
adroites des mains de fée ce n'est pas
suffisant on exige aussi de la meilleure
ménagères de france des connaissances
précises et c'est le moment que jamais d
exprimer clairement la sélection est
sévère de ses 120 concurrente des demi
finales il ne restera que 20 rescapés
pour affronter la finale
les voici cette année nos vins lauréate
avait rendez vous chez crizal ce fut un
aimable divertissement
l'irruption de la technique du 20e
siècle parmi les femmes savantes
dernière épreuve pour les championnes de
l'art ménagers convaincre philaminte et
belize des miracles de l'électricité du
gaz de la mécanique avec martine martine
la soubrette au solide bon sens c'est
plus facile à l'est conquise par la
matière peste
[Musique]
rené manger l'auteur du divertissement
philaminte abdiquent devant les pouvoirs
de la machine à laver
la fée du logis gagnera non seulement
son joli titre mais aussi des
instruments de sa puissance deux
cuisinières à gaz à l'électricité
une machine à laver une machine à coudre
et bien d'autres cadeaux le xviie siècle
souri à la technique moderne
leur approche on va connaître l'heureuse
lauréate
on apprend d'abord le nom de ses
suivants annick lottin 17 ans d'ille et
vilaine jacqueline père à 18 ans venus
de la corrèze la fée du logis
la fée du logis c'est madame paulette
lavaud 26 ans présenté par la caisse
d'allocations familiales de reims elle
est mariée elle a deux enfants crizal
gageons le envieraient son époux
[Musique]